ليس هناك شك في أن الأمور
ستبدو مختلفة في العمل في المرة الأولى
التي تذهب فيها إلى هناك أولاً وقبل كل شيء
سيرتدي الجميع واحدة من هذه في
مكان عملنا ، ستكون قاعدة ،
شيء آخر أفعله عندما أذهب إلى المستشفى هو
أنني أبقى دائمًا عاريًا في الأسفل  الكوع بهذه
الطريقة لا تتلوث ساعتي أو مجوهراتي ، كما أن حلقي
لا يتلوث ، كما أنه من الأسهل أيضًا غسل
الأيدي التي
تتحدث عنها والتي تحمل معقمًا لليدين
الآن أعتقد أن معظمكم ربما يفعلون ذلك
أيضًا ، لكن أماكن العمل ستجعل
الأمر أسهل عادةً من خلال وجود محطات
مثل  هذا إذا كان بإمكانك أن تكون
فكرة أفضل دائمًا أن تصعد السلالم ،
ولكن إذا كان عليك أن تأخذ مصعدًا ،
فضع في اعتبارك أن هذا سيكون أحد
المواقف الأكثر خطورة ، لذا من الواضح
أنه مساحة صغيرة في الداخل ، حاول العثور على
مصعد ليس ذلك
يجب على الجميع مواجهة الازدحام في نفس
الاتجاه لتقليل انتشار
الفيروس واستخدام شيء مثل القلم
للضغط على الزر حتى لا
تقول أنك تريد التفكير في كل
سطح تلمسه  لابد من
التفكير في أن هذه الأبواب
ستظل مفتوحة على الأرجح حتى لا
تضطر إلى لمس المقابض ، فسيقوم
الجميع بتطهير
جميع أسطحهم ، وهذا
أمر شائع جدًا أيضًا عند التفكير في المكان
الذي تجلس فيه ومن يجلس
بجوارك ، سترغب في ترك مساحة من
الواضح بهذه الطريقة ولكن أيضًا حاول ألا
تجلس مباشرة أمام شخص ما
لأنك تريد تقليل
الانتقال الفيروسي كان هناك طابق واحد في
كوريا الجنوبية وفقًا لهذه الدراسة
حيث حصل 94 شخصًا على  مصاب ، هذا
ما تحاول تجنبه هنا
وبالمناسبة ، تبدأ هذه العملية برمتها التي وصفتها للتو
حتى قبل أن تأتي إلى العمل ، قم بقياس
درجة حرارتك في المنزل ، وإذا كان لديك
أي أعراض ، فمن الواضح أنه يجب عليك البقاء
هناك